and a fire like this has not been seen
here for years rows of dead bodies
evidence of The Inferno that engulfed
the building in Johannesburg City
Center people were jumping we heard
people screaming and some of them they
were jumping with their
luggages there was fire too much smoke
and uh the fire started from the first
floor of the flat going up
so the people inside the floor the ones
who at the third floor fourth floor it
was difficult for them to escape the
fire as the search and Recovery
operation began treasure Lee looked for
her missing daughter Janet she had lived
there for about a year the five-story
building was abandoned but home to many
illegal occupants I'm confused I'm
scared I'm
traumatized you name them I I really I
just want to see my daughter alive
that's that's all that I want whether
she's burned whether she's I just want
to see her the fire started in the early
hours of the morning while many slept
giving them little time to escape from
overcrowded conditions the building was
leased by the city to a non-government
organization which looks after homeless
people and drug addicts if you suspect
that you have lost your beloved
one go to Frei Street they will assist
you but many ref refused to move
watching and waiting for word about
their loved ones wondering where they'll
sleep tonight some hang on to the little
they could grab as they ran from the
building while it took firefighters
about 2 hours to extinguish the Flames
the search and Recovery operations have
gone on for far longer than that police
are investigating what caused the fire
and why the building was illegally
occupied and
overcrowded City officials say there are
at least 700 abandoned buildings here
which are being illegally sublet taken
over by informal landlords charging
people for accommodation many survivors
don't know where they'll sleep next for
Treasure Lee all she can do now is look
for her daughter in nearby hospitals and
morgs fam Miller Al jaaz
Johannesburg well leanda Tami is a
housing Rights Campaign and he joins us
now from Cape Town great to have you
with us perhaps you can help us
understand why so many people are forced
to live in these abandoned
buildings first and foremost thank you
for having me and deest condolences to
the families that have lost their loved
ones and our prayers go to um the
families that their loved ones are in
hospital H one thing that I think I must
first clarify is
that
shelter it's a shelter shelter that was
operated by the city of
Johannesburg that was meant for women
and children that H have been abused but
the city of Johannesburg neglected and
left that building to be the way it is
now it is quite disturbing then that now
we are seeing the city of Johannesburg
blaming H the the residents of that
building blaming the Civil Society
organizations
um for their own failure for neglecting
the building for failing um to fulfill
their obligation through their
constitutional obligation it's quite
suddening and for them to use the
strategy um um um as a political gain to
try to gain some political points it's
sad and it's disturbing as well we have
seen politicians from both ANC and da
coming out and using this tragedy to
gain political points it's sad and it's
disgusting as well but the the
government I mean the city authorities
they say they can't move people from
these buildings unless they've got
alternative accommodation for them and
they simply don't have that alternative
accommodation
available that's that's that's that's
the biggest issue that all
municipalities in fact in South Africa
have is that they lost touch of the
ground they've lost touch on what is
happening on the ground the issue of
Housing and lack of housing in South
Africa it's an issue that has been
raised many many many years it's not an
issue that is only coming now but we
have seen municipalities not having
plans for that instead what they are
doing is that they're only promising
people with pipelines project that never
materialize and that's a that's a huge
issue we are currently seeing in all
municipalities that people are moving in
the inner cities people are occupying in
the inner city because what is happening
is that people that are living in the
township need to commute long distances
and long hours to to access work and
going back home they're doing the same
thing and they're spending they're
spending some of them they're even
spending 50% of their salaries towards
transport towards taxes and people
that's why people have ended up having
to occupy spaces that are close to their
their work their work their work places
and we have seen the city we have seen
municipalities and actually in all
spheres of government not addressing
this issue of special Injustice you know
the history of South Africa that
during during arate most of most of the
black and colored people were moved away
from the inner city but we have not seen
that people black and color people be
moved into the city but what is the
solution then do you think people should
be moved on from these buildings and
rehomed in more habitable places or
should they be allowed to stay and
should the city take charge of these
buildings and give them the services
that they need and make them safe to
live
in so what what needs to happen is that
first and foremost there has to be a
meaningful engagement with communities
which the city the municipalities are
failing on there has to be a meaningful
engagement and the the amicable solution
must be reached and agreed by both
parties not the city of cap toown that
has not the city not the municipalities
that have lost touch of the ground to
come with solutions that are actually
further
um making sure that people have forced
away from Forced away from the city from
the M from the inner city so what will
be a solution here is that municipality
they have they must have a meaningful
engagement and consult with communities
to reach a suitable
solution okay Luanda mamelli thanks very
much for taking the time to join us
there from Cape
Town